Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute einen Schaumkuchen und ich habe mir gedacht gerade weil aktuell das Wetter
auch so heiß ist und die Sonne ist da sollte es ein Rezept sein, für das ihr den Backofen nicht anschmeißen müsst.
Und wir starten jetzt zuallererst mit dem Boden.
Ich mache jetzt einen Boden aus dem Mr.Creamy Keksen von K-Classics von Kaufland.
Das sind diese hier. Die werde ich jetzt hier ganz einfach fein mixen
und anschließend kommt da einfach ein bisschen geschmolzene Butter dazu
und das ist dann schon unser Boden.
Die Butter vermischt ihr dann zusammen mit den Keksen und das ist quasi unser No Bake Boden,
der eignet sich nämlich so immer perfekt für solche Torten und Kuchen.
Und den gebt ihr jetzt einfach auf den Boden eurer Schnittenform,
ich nehme heute nämlich die Schnittenform.
Ihr könntet das Rezept natürlich umwandeln und ein ganzes Blech vollmachen,
das ist vollkommen euch überlassen.
Ich kann auch gerne auch meine Umrechnungstabelle in die Infobox verlinken
genauso wie alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
So, das habe ich jetzt hier noch glatt verstrichen und schön angedrückt
und das kommt jetzt bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt eine richtig coole und ausgeklügelte Creme!
(H: *lacht* Was war das denn?)
Na weil die so ausgeklügelt ist!
(H: Mach nochmal diese-diesen..)
Creme!
So, kommen wir zu unserer ausgeklügelten Creme! Dafür benötigen wir tatsächlich auch nur drei Zutaten.
Und zwar Milch, Sahne und dann habe ich als dritte Zutat Cremepulver.
Das ist nicht Puddingpulver, das ist ja dann zum Kochen.
Wir brauchen aber eins, das ihr nur zum Aufschlagen verwendet. Das heißt: ein Cremepulver,
das ihr nicht einkochen müsst. Das seht ihr auch anhand der Packungsanleitung.
Und ihr müsst aber - ganz wichtig - auf meine Mengenangaben achten,
denn ich habe hier z.B. die Milch ein bisschen reduziert, wir wollen ja eine feste Tortencreme
und nicht einfach eine Creme zum Löffeln.
So und jetzt machen wir folgendes: wir vermischen jetzt ganz einfach alles in der Küchenmaschine,
ihr könntet aber auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
Die Milch, die hab ich abgewogen. Gebe ich hier einmal rein, Sahne mit rein
dann das Pulver mit dazu und dann ganz einfach aufschlagen.
Und die Schaum-Creme ist fertig, ungefähr 2-3min hat's bei mir gedauert
und jetzt gebe ich das ganz einfach auf den vorbereiteten Boden und streiche das
noch so ein bisschen glatt, das geht aber in der Regel wie von alleine.
So und jetzt heißt es: ganz viel Geduld zeigen! Ich bin selbst ein mega ungeduldiger Mensch
aber wenn es um Torten geht und ich weiß nach der Kühlzeit schmecken sie richtig richtig gut,
dann halte ich das auch aus! Also mindestens 4h in den Kühlschrank damit,
noch besser wäre natürlich über Nacht, dann könnt ihr das ja auch am Vortag zubereiten,
ganz chillig am nächsten Tag verspeisen. Und wenn ihr möchtet - das mache ich nämlich so -
gebt ihr obendrauf noch ein bisschen Zartbitterkuvertüre oder Vollmilch wenn ihr mögt
oder weiße Kuvertüre geht auch. Ich raspel das dann ganz schön oben drauf
und dann ist eigentlich mein Schaumkuchen fertig! Und das Ganze No Bake, super schnell, super einfach,
wenig Zutaten und die Zutaten bekommt ihr natürlich alle bei Kaufland.
Und ansonsten würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr mir unten in die Kommentare schreibt,
was ihr als nächstes sehen möchtet. Mehr No Bake Rezepte?
Vielleicht passend zum Sommer irgendwelche Grillrezepte?
Schreibt's mir gerne rein!
(H: Cocktails!)
Cocktails, super gute Idee! Alkoholfreie Cocktails.
Und dann ja, würde ich mal sagen sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
Ach und folgt uns auf Instagram, da gibt's dann den Taste-Test zu dieser Schaumtorte
oder diesem Schaumkuchen!
Bis bald, Tschüss!